hey guys how's it going guess what i'm
wearing glasses and you know why i'm
wearing glasses it's because they're
prescription and i can't see recently on
instagram i don't know why this is a
recent thing but i post pictures of
myself because that's what people do on
instagram selfie i will never hashtag
selfie by far the most annoying thing
ever but that's a whole nother story
people have been commenting telling me
that i'm a hipster because i'm wearing
glasses let me tell you what i'm not
having a good time wearing glasses i'm
wearing glasses because i cannot see if
i don't wear them i cannot see you
prescription sunglasses prescription
don't believe me great here's another
prescription pair prescription oh look
at this more prescription prescription
not prescription more prescriptions
i can't see if i wear multiple pairs of
glasses does this make me more hipster
what is a hipster what does it even mean
i don't even know hold on a second i'll
look it up for you when i'm done putting
all of my glasses on more than one pair
of glasses means more hipster oh we're
not done yet because guess what we have
sunglasses cool now i'm probably not
even gonna be able to am i wearing all
of them don't know can't see
define hipster siri i'm on it here's
what i found oh okay hipster english
word definition someone who rejects the
established culture advocates extreme
liberalism in politics and lifestyle
look at me just advocating
liberalism look at me rejecting culture
wearing more than one pair of glasses
i'm getting a migraine because i'm
wearing so many glasses
so so hipster
siri who am i
you're justine but you asked me to call
you my it's true i definitely did
ask you to call me that anyway this is
just my small rant on
don't even know i don't even know what
i'm ranting about people yelling at me
for wearing glasses because i can't see
i mean these are contacts if you haven't
noticed
oh no now i mixed them all up have a
nice day
see you guys later let me know if any of
you guys have a prescription
site problem can you see can you not see
leave me a comment i'll see you later
i'm gonna go post more selfies of myself
on instagram with all of the glasses
you